buonasera a tutti
francesca è il mestiere faccio la
ricercatrice biomedica presso jones 13
mesi nutrition da tradizione incontro
innovazione questo è il tema di oggi e
penso che sono slogan particolarmente un
peccato per la ricerca perché la ricerca
comunque campo sia ha sempre l'obiettivo
principale di migliorare lo stato
attuale delle cose con nuove scoperte di
iniziare punto le innovazioni a partire
da quanto noto lo stato dell'arte quella
che è considerata appunto la tradizione
e questo succede anche nel mio campo è
quello dei materiali
infatti noi partiamo da tutto quello che
ci circonda che conosciamo più o meno
nei dettagli e cerchiamo di produrre
materiali sempre nuovi e più innovativi
ma di bra in pratica noi che cosa
facciamo noi piccoli ricercatori cosa
facciamo il laboratorio accusiamo un
approccio abbastanza rigoroso infatti
studiamo l'argomento leggendo la
letteratura
facciamo tutti facciamo delle ipotesi a
riguardo poi andiamo in laboratorio
sperimentiamo raccogliamo i risultati e
cerchiamo di interpretarli per arrivare
nelle nostre conclusioni
in tutto questo processo di solito ne
abbiamo sempre appunto delle idee di
cosa aspettarci però come dice il
proverbio spesso le migliori scoperte
avvengono per caso e in quel caso la
bravura sta proprio nel capire
l'evento inaspettato cercare poi appunto
di spiegarlo è oggi parto proprio con
una domanda secca a voi per alzata di
mano
quanti di voi userebbero il vetro per
rigenerare l'osso la cartilagine nessuno
neanche la mia famiglia non importa
vi capisco perché anch'io la prima volta
che ho sentito questa idea
all'università ero molto scettica però
vi posso dire che adesso una decina
d'anni che lavora nel campo e l'uso del
vetro anzi del bio vetro come materiale
per rigenerare l'osso è considerato
abbastanza tradizionale
la nostra ricerca ed è appunto quello di
cui voglio parlare oggi partendo dal
vetro che allora il vetro è un materiale
che tutti noi conosciamo ed è
particolarmente apprezzato per la sua
trasparenza e dal punto di vista chimico
ha una struttura elementare che quella
che vedete nella slide è un tetraedro di
silice che si dispone in maniera
totalmente disordinata nello spazio
badate bene che se prendete lo stesso
tetraedro e lo disponete in modo
perfettamente ordinato ottenete dei
cristalli di quarzo come quelli in
figura
invece se l'organizzazione e random
otteniamo un vetro è proprio questa
struttura dal vetro la trasparenza ma
noi piccoli scienziati la possibilità di
modificare la chimica in modo
relativamente facile per cambiarne le
proprietà e questo ci ha portato nel
tempo a passare dalla produzione di
piccolissimi pannelli di vetro come
quelli del del pub che vedete in figura
a coprire interi palazzi in vetro come
ad esempio lo shard di londra poi
abbiamo vetri anti graffio vetri
autopulenti e bio vetri allora com'è che
si è passati da questi vetri o un vetro
da mettere all'interno del corpo umano
il papà del bio vetro professor rienzi
che vedete nella slide insieme al mio
supervisor la scoperta in modo
abbastanza fortuito tornando quello che
abbiamo detto prima infatti si trovava
in una stava andando ad una cena sociale
di una conferenza e si ritrova seduto
sul pullman di fianco un colonnello
dell'esercito americano e iniziò
raccontarli tutte le cose belle che
stava facendo
mi occupo di materiali elettrici
resistenti alle radiazioni e il
colonnello lo guarda gli disse guarda a
noi non interessano tanto quei materiali
noi vorremmo un materiale che sia in
grado di resistere all'interno del corpo
umano che non venga rigettato
e questo perché al colonnello stesso ero
appena tornato dalla guerra del vietnam
e aveva visto tantissimi soldati che
avevano subito amputazioni a causa di
materiali di corpi estranei che si erano
conficcati all'interno dell'osso e è in
ci disse che questa conversazione cambiò
per sempre la sua vita tornò in
laboratorio e inizia a pensare come
poter risolvere questo problema e penso
posso usare il vetro perché il vetro
posso lavorare sulla sua chimica e posso
ad esempio inserire calcio e fosforo
questi sono due elementi che sono tipici
appunto dell'osso e la sua idea era se
io prendo un vetro riduco la silice
aggiungo i due elementi magari le
cellule non lo vedono più come strano lo
vedono come parte del nostro stesso
quindi preparò il primi campioni e
l'idea di un suo amico un chirurgo il
quale li limite all'interno di posizioni
all'interno di femore di ratti facce
degli studi e dopo un po di settimane lo
richiamo agli dicendo guardi lei riesce
un problema è in ci disse non ti
preoccupare era solo il primo materiale
posso fare di molto meglio e disse non
ho il problema è che io non riesco a
togliere questo il tuo materiale
dall'osso perché si è completamente
integrato con esse quindi io non posso
studiarlo non posso farli nelle
caratterizzazioni e questa era la prima
volta che si vedeva una cosa del genere
un materiale che interagisce attivamente
colosso tanto da diventare un tutt'uno
con esso non solo non veniva rigettato
ero piaceva all'osso
era il 1969 nacque così il bio vetro
detto baio glass porti files five in
inglese e così apre anche un nuovo
filone di ricerca quello dei vetri
bioattivi della rigenerazione ossea dei
materiali usi induttivi e cose di questo
genere è il primo obiettivo cercare di
capire come questo succedeva
dopo diversi studi si è capito che il
vetro obiettivo nel momento in cui viene
inserito all'interno dell'osso non solo
non genera di getto ma le cellule
riconoscono questo materiale iniziano a
parlare attraverso un meccanismo di
scambio ionico appunto di ogni calcio e
fossero quelli detto prima in questo
scambio di doni stimola le cellule a
produrre nuovo osso e mentre questo
succede e bio vetro si degrada lasciando
quindi spazio hanno mosso una cosa
eccezionale vedo alcune fasce
assolutamente lo fa sul serio e quindi
una cosa nuova che funziona cerchiamo di
metterla sul mercato è una ventina
d'anni ormai che il bio vetro e sul
mercato sotto forma di polvere come
quella che vedete in figura
ed è sul mercato in un mondo ortopedico
sotto diversi nomi commerciali questo è
un esempio e da una polverina che viene
mischiata con il sangue del paziente per
formare una specie di pasta che viene
inserito all'interno dell'osso e stimola
supporto l'osso nella sua origine
l'azione questo viene usato ad esempio
nel caso di asportazione di tumori o
lacune o se per traumi eccetera
però quello che ho visto per di più è
che chiunque si lavi i denti con questo
dentifricio
in realtà si lava i 20 col detto come si
lava i denti colpito perché c'è il vetro
in forma di particelle e non è una cosa
negativa non vi preoccupate perché il
bio vetro stimola la rimineralizzazione
dei tubuli dentinali che sono queste
cavità che vedete e questo riduce la
sensibilità dentale non mi pagano per
dirla non vi preoccupate
il grande problema è però nel campo
ortopedico quello delle articolazioni
perché le articolazioni come le vostre
ginocchia lean che c'è tra queste sono
zone in cui le pressioni e le forze sono
molto alte e quindi una pasta non è più
sufficiente ci vuole qualcosa che di un
supporto strutturale e quindi noi
scienziati abbiamo iniziato a pensare di
studiare delle strutture di questo tipo
che chiamiamo scaffold alla parola scafo
dall'inglese significa ponteggio
impalcatura
e questo perché esattamente come nel
campo dell'architettura
il suo obiettivo è quello di guidare
supportare la rigenerazione e mentre
scomparire man mano che questa procede
forse in questo video si vede un po
meglio allora qui c'è una nostra una
lacuna osseo e come vedrete dopo la
struttura dell'osso all'interno una
struttura spugnosa il nostro obiettivo è
avere il nostro scaffold posizionarlo
nel difetto e lo scafo deve essere
poroso con dei pori interconnessi e
questo perché in questo modo il sangue
può circolare all'interno migrare in
tutto volume
nel farlo porta delle cellule che se il
materiale è un materiale da adatto si
attaccano lo scafo e iniziano a produrre
il nuovo osso e mentre questo succede
allo scafo il pian piano scompare
lasciando spazio hanno mosso un po come
la pelle si cicatrizza quando si era
assorbono i punti di strutture in poche
parole il problema è che il mio vetro
sarebbe perfetto per questo tipo di
applicazione ma è sempre un vetro quindi
è fragile
quindi non è in grado di resistere a
urti noi li chiamiamo di schianto
d'impatto noi non vogliamo che dentro al
nostro anca si spacchi di colpo se per
caso
siamo facciamo una cosa un incidente e
qui entra in gioco la mia ricerca perché
serve un'altra innovazione per
migliorare il bio vetro e nel nostro
gruppo noi utilizziamo un tipo di
approccio molto particolare che è quello
di generare dei materiali ibridi
allora che cosa intendiamo per materia
l'ibrido ibrido al momento è una parola
molto di moda perché ci sono animali
ibridi frutta ibrida verdura ibrida e
per noi significa mischiare il vetro che
bioattivo e biodegradabile insieme a una
plastica in modo da migliorarne la
flessibilità ed elasticità un po la voce
è però noi non lo facciamo come si
farebbe in un materiale composito sia
non prendiamo il vetro e la plastica le
prepariamo separatamente e le mischiamo
perché in questo modo quello che si
ottiene un materiale che come vedete lì
c'è un interfaccia tra le fasi sono
separate questo potrebbe dare dei
problemi
quello che noi facciamo è di nuovo
giochiamo sulla chimica del materiale
quindi mescoliamo il vetro e la plastica
in fase di produzione mentre lo
sintetizziamo in questo modo le molecole
si parlano si entrano in contatto con
legami chimici e quello che si ottiene
un materiale nuovo
un materiale completamente omogeneo come
quello che vedete in figura trasparente
che non è un vetro non è una plastica
non è un mix dei due è un ibrido che
coniuga le proprietà dei due ma tre di
partenza mi ci è voluto un po per
arrivare a questi materiali non sia
arrivato in modo molto semplice come si
vede nella slide dopo finalmente ci
siamo riusciti abbiamo un materiale che
è in grado di resistere degli urti
come vedete senza spaccarsi esempio una
martellata e continuo a contenere m
obiettivo quindi continua a stimolare la
rigenerazione e la cosa fantastica è che
questi ibridi hanno anche aperto un
nuovo campo di ricerca perché non
parliamo solo pd osso infatti quello che
si trova sulla sinistra che quello che
io ho sviluppato durante il mio
dottorato è in grado di stimolare
attivamente la rigenerazione della
cartilagine
questo perché innanzitutto per le
proprietà meccaniche perché come vedete
è in grado di rimbalzare infatti noi lo
chiamiamo bouncy baio glass
che significa il vetro che rimbalza se
voi pensate alla cartilagine ad esempio
su di toccate le orecchie la punta del
naso
significa che il materiale è in grado di
recuperare la sua deformazione e quindi
simbolo appunto la cartilagine
il secondo motivo è rappresentato dalla
tecnica di produzione che permette la
stampa 3d
cioè noi nel momento in cui preparemo
questi libri di abbiamo una fase in cui
questi ibridi sono dei gel enel questi
gel possono essere stampati direttamente
in tre dimensioni per produrre gli scafo
di cui vi parlavo prima
e non vi ho specificato ma questi
scaffold sono scaffold con canali molto
molto piccoli infatti sono della
dimensione dell'ordine un po più grande
del diametro di un capello
e questo perché non solo abbiamo
lavorato sui materiali ma anche le
tecnologie sono migliorate e questo
hanno permesso di arrivare a sviluppare
e lavorare in materia di una scala
sempre più piccola e in ultima cosa
questo materiale è stato dimostrato da
prove cellulari che è in grado di
stimolare non la rigenerazione dell'osso
maniera rigenerazione della cartilagine
articolare e per questo vi chiedo quanti
di voi hanno un problema alla
cartilagine o conoscono in una persona
che abbia problemi alla cartilagine meno
più del 50 per cento della sala e come
vedete anche da questi problemi è un
problema molto grande e molto diffuso e
il problema della carta delle fratture
dell'azienda cartilagini ancora reso
peggiore dal fatto che la cartilagine a
differenza dell'osso non è in grado di
auto ripararsi gelose in grado di
saldare qualche frattura
solo quando sono troppo grandi c'è
bisogno di un supporto alla cartilagine
invece non è in grado di farlo e quindi
se ci sono delle lesioni
queste con il tempo non si attendono
semplicemente a peggiorare e l'ultima
soluzione solo quelli una protesi cosa
che non vogliamo assolutamente per un
individuo giovane
per quanto riguarda questo bouncy palace
noi l'abbiamo brevettato ma non è ancora
un dispositivo medico
ci stiamo lavorando e questo perché nel
nostro campo purtroppo per fortuna le
regolamentazioni sono tante e interessa
fare sono
però prevediamo una decina d'anni prima
di sapere se ce l'avremmo fatta o meno è
quello che vi chiedo se in tutto questo
tempo continuate a prendervi quello
delle vostre articolazioni e tenete le
dita incrociate
noi ve lo aspettate non è finita perché
tornando al discorso delle scoperte
inaspettate mentre studiavo questo
materiale abbiamo anche scoperto
un'altra proprietà quella di
autoripararsi in modo autonomo
non ce lo aspettavamo minimamente
tagliavamo dei campioni per fare delle
prove abbiamo visto che erano in grado
di tornare insieme di saldarsi
semplicemente schiacciandoli un pochino
e anche in questo caso è stato scoperto
in modo casuale perché io ero ad un
meeting con il mio capo li avevo portato
dei campioni e lui giocandoci perché era
super eccitato da questa abilità di
rimbalzare nemmeno aveva cliccato 1
succede a tutte le volte e quindi a fine
del meeting modo per recuperare questo
campione a buttarlo ma non trovo più la
cricca non c'era più avevo solo tre
campioni quindi era impossibile che
viene forse perso 1 e subito ci siamo
resi conto che succedeva qualcosa di
assolutamente inaspettato che valeva la
pena di continuare a investigare e
questo insieme al fatto che comunque un
andiamo sempre il laboratorio per
generare cose che speriamo in un futuro
possano migliorare la vita della gente e
quello che mi appassiona tantissimo del
mio lavoro e con questo questa volta vi
ringrazio tutti quanti
[Applauso]